have you done much thinking about the  nature of consciousness i know that  you've spoken about free will and time  and indeterminacy  consciousness no you know i'm a  physicist i'm not a philosopher so even  about free will  which is certainly uh something which i  think uh is a  an important concept but it's not a  concept of physics  uh so i i you know and consciousness  probably even less so i don't know if  it's less or but i mean there's a  certain number of concepts that are  completely outside of today's physics  whether they will ever be  within physics i don't know um  so maybe i should indeed  warn you and everyone uh listening to  this that i'm not a philosopher i don't  claim to be a philosopher  uh and i certainly claim that uh  consciousness free will and the mind or  things like that  uh fascinating concepts we all know that  we we have that  but these are not concepts that belong  to today's physics possibly not even  to future physics